all right tonight with so many crises
here at home and abroad and many woke
democrats obsessed with vilifying uh
unfairly florida governor ron desantis
and that new law that bans teachers from
having inappropriate sexual agenda
theory conversations with kids in pre-k
through third grade four five six seven
and eight okay eager to jump on any
left-wing bandwagon texas democrat bezo
boto bozo o'rourke is out there posting
this creepy picture of himself wearing a
t-shirt that says don't mess with trans
kids meanwhile the disney corporation
and their woke employees and leaders
have been well absolutely
out of their minds over this new law
some recently staged a walkout in
protest and disney is now banning gender
terms like boy and girl like ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls children of all
i can't say that anymore governor
desantis is fighting back threatening to
remove many of disney's special
privileges that they get from the
sunshine state because of their woke
political theatrics take a look
i think what has happened is there's a
lot of these special privileges that are
not justifiable but because disney had
held so much sway they were able to
sustain a lot of special treatment over
the years the state should be governed
by the best interests of the people you
should not have one organization that is
able to dictate policy
in all these different realms and they
have done that for many many years and
if that stops now which it should that
would be a good thing for florida
here with reaction brand new fox news
contributor caitlyn jenner we welcome
you to the fox family um one thing you
said to me
uh when when i heard and and we've known
each other for many many years we go
back decades
you said
you know i did all this stuff on reality
tv and i enjoyed it i had fun doing it
and and all your obvious
uh accomplishments in athletics he said
i'm over that part of my life this
country's in deep trouble that's where
your head is at that's where your focus
is
explain
it certainly is uh that's one of the
reasons i ran for governor is we have to
stand up we have to have america has to
have a stand-up mentality
um yes i have done a lot in my life um
going all the way back uh to the
olympics um i
had a lot of talks actually even with
you sean and other people at fox when we
were negotiating this deal
as you know as you might know i am trans
and but i'm not a trans activist um
that's just one part of my life uh
there's so much more to me um but i
think in the next in the midterms coming
up
lgbt issues are going to be very big
issues and i'm looking forward to
covering those but there's so much more
to me than that
obviously in 1976
i think was the best olympics of all
time it was our our bicentennial our
country was 200 years old patriotism was
at its height i have been a patriot my
whole life and my father fought in world
war ii my mother's 95
hi mom
and
she's a patriot i grew up that way and i
want to i want that to continue i want
to
i was so proud to be the first person to
put the american flag up and i want to i
want to continue that
let me ask you this because and and you
you could talk about a variety of
subjects you know
in the case of florida first of all the
word gay is not in the bill you know so
it's ridiculous they're talking about
kids pre-k
through third grade now most of our kids
can't graduate and with a reading level
that is proficient say that we're not
proficient in math science english uni
you know the important core issues how
about we teach the kids that and then if
parents and schools if they want to have
all these whoa classes after school the
parents can opt their kids in let's do
it that way but let's educate our kids
with the basics first but good idea bad
idea i got about 40 seconds
great
it's it's i'm a common sense person and
that is what you call common sense um
i had 10 children i raised help raised
10 children i have 20 grandchildren
i am all for parental rights
yes one grandchildren and family by the
way and your kids are like
these kids
combined they may own more than half the
country
uh all right uh caleb i i i did a good
job yeah yeah i did a good job with him
and this and that but honestly i was
holding my one week old granddaughter
um little goldie jenner
real quick just last week and i was
thinking what's
yeah what's there for you what are you
going to do what's her life going to be
like yeah well and uh i want to help you
go to the board i got to say goodbye uh
we'll have you back soon when we come
back the great one mark levine weighs in
on hunter's laptop hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else